filas interminables en la oficina de
pasaportes en kabul los afganos están
desesperados por conseguir documentos de
viaje algunos frustrados por los
oficiales de seguridad talibán
burbuja la gente ha venido aquí para
obtener sus pasaportes porque los
funcionarios anunciaron que es pedirían
25.000 más hemos venido aquí a primera
hora desde las 4 de la mañana para hacer
clic hay mucha gente y no hay orden y
disciplina dejó atrás a liu el pasado 6
de octubre los talibanes dijeron que
reanudarían la emisión de pasaportes el
proceso había sido suspendido desde la
caída del gobierno de áfrica ni en
agosto el número de afganos que intentan
cruzar las fronteras del país se ha
disparado desde entonces como aquí en la
frontera de sara con irán el éxodo de
personas ha aumentado de 1000 a casi
4.000 al día
acnur dice que los donantes
internacionales deben proporcionar la
ayuda prometida con urgencia para ayudar
a prevenir nuevos flujos de desplazados
y refugiados en un país de 40 millones
de personas que ha pasado por más de 40
años
y
la mitad de ellos casi 20 millones
incluso antes de los sucesos del 15 de
agosto dependían de la ayuda humanitaria
y hemos visto que este año durante el
2021 hasta ahora casi 700 mil afganos
han sido desplazados solo este año es
decir mientras tanto los talibanes han
comenzado a enviar al norte del país a
las personas que huyeron de su toma del
poder en agosto y que vivían en tiendas
de campaña en un parque de kabul los
talibanes afirman que no disponen de
fondos para devolver a la gran mayoría
de los desplazados a sus hogares